one of the most common myths that I hear
is that if unused muscle tissue converts
into fact from pregnancy myths
pregnant women should admit to myths
about going gluten-free in order to lose
weight free for weight loss can be a
huge marketing ploy there are tons of
misconceptions when it comes to the
human body whether it's about exercise
or mental illness a lot of the stuff
that you hear isn't exactly true we had
experts visit our studio to debunk some
of the most common myths in the world of
health and well-being first up we have
two experts debunk 15 of the most common
myths about sleep alright many adults
need five hours of sleep or less now
this is a myth loud snoring is annoying
but mostly harmless loud snoring is
actually a sign that there is a blockage
in your throat your brain and body will
adapt to Leslie this is a myth
I'm dr. Rebecca Robbins I'm a
postdoctoral research fellow at the
Brigham and Women's Hospital and Harvard
Medical School and I'm dr. David
Rappaport I'm a professor of medicine at
the Icahn School of Medicine at Mount
Sinai and I run the research program in
sleep and we're here today to debunk
some of the most common myths about our
sleep watching TV in bed is a good way
to relax before sleep now this is not
something that we would necessarily
recommend you turn the television on and
if it's close to you that's the source
of bright blue light so bright light is
one of the strongest cues to our
circadian rhythm it kick-starts our body
and our brain to become awake and alert
in the morning it's called a sight
gerbera the strongest input to that
circadian the awake phase of our rhythm
drinking booze before bed will improve
your sleep so this is a very commonly
used tactic for people who have trouble
sleeping and they have a drink it's a
drug it's very much like a sleeping pill
and it is true that it will help you get
to sleep as long as you don't drink too
much one or two drinks perhaps what you
do however is it disrupts the normal
sleep it suppresses REM sleep which is a
normal
part of your sleep that comes on a
little while after you go to sleep
typically 30 to 60 minutes later and
then when it comes that the alcohol has
gotten out of your system then the REM
comes back perhaps at the wrong time
perhaps too strong and it disrupts
things and so basically it is not
generally recommended that alcohol be
used as a sleeping pill all right lie in
bed with your eyes closed is almost as
good as sleeping I think that one's
pretty definitely not correct sleep is a
very specific process that your body
goes through most common myth if you
will that we got rid of in the
scientific field 50 years ago is that
sleep was like you know taking your car
and putting in the garage and turning
off the key and leaving it there and
then you come back the next morning and
it just is parked sleep is not like that
at all sleep is a very active process
when you go to sleep you into one stage
a little while lady you enter another
stage it gets progressively deeper you
then have the REM sleep and then you
wake up momentarily and that whole cycle
takes an hour to an hour and a half and
then it starts again and it happens
three to five times at a night and if
you disrupt any of that something
happens and the next morning you feel it
you don't feel rested now we don't
understand how that actually happens or
why that happens but we do know it does
happen so when you're lying in bed none
of that is happening if your eyes are
closed and you're not asleep it just
doesn't count next if you can't sleep
you should stay in bed and try to fall
back asleep if you don't fall asleep we
generally recommend that you not stretch
it out by and stress yourself out by
just trying and there's probably nothing
that can prevent sleep as well as I've
got it go to sleep I've got to go to
sleep I've got to feel your pulse and
your blood pressure going up so what we
try and do when we work with somebody
who has this problem with insomnia is
exactly the opposite of that we try and
tell them relax don't worry about it
stay in bed for a little while and see
what happens but don't try to go to
sleep just relax and if you can't relax
and if you don't go to sleep it's
probably better to get up so that you
don't associate the bed
the stressful situation all right many
adults need five hours of sleep or less
now this is a myth we have scores of
epidemiological data and data from the
sleep lab to show that five hours is not
enough for the vast majority of adults
there may be some individuals that may
be due ok on on six hours but much less
than that really is a myth now you might
hear people brag about this saying you
know oh I do know I get five I'm just
fine but by and large we do see those
people likely making up for lost sleep
on the weekends or Empowered apps for
instance so for the vast majority of us
the recommendation really is seven seven
to eight hours this is a real problem
with their sleep field has been trying
to address and that is that not sleeping
has been perceived as a macho thing it
proves how great you are proves how
manly you are in some cases sleeping is
actually good you should sort of be
proud of the fact that you sleep - your
need your brain and body will adapt to
less sleep sounds like yours no this is
a myth if you see that just like good
nutrition or a great healthy diet is so
important we similarly have a diet that
we need our brains and our bodies to be
at their best there are actual formal
studies that have tested how people
perform with lack of sleep and how they
think they are performing and it turns
out that we basically are really lousy
at saying how sleepy we are so you know
you feel bad when you haven't or not
enough asleep but you have no idea how
bad you are and your performance keeps
deteriorating the more you don't sleep
or restrict your sleep over multiple
days and you think oh I've settled in I
you know I have a little headache it
doesn't really bother me I'm doing just
great and what actually is happening is
you're performing less and less well on
the various things that we can test
including driving simulators you're
falling asleep for three or four seconds
continuously without knowing it alright
it doesn't matter what time of day you
sleep if you look at our biology we have
inside our brain a clock that clock is
set to say this is a good time to sleep
and then
at another time it says this is a good
time to be out sleep is timed it doesn't
just happen and even if you don't sleep
for the whole night you'll be more and
more sleepy all night long but in the
morning you'll get a second wind and
that's because the clock says up time to
be up doesn't matter that you didn't
sleep it's time to be up as Rebecca said
we've gained an incredible ability to
not abide by that rhythm and the problem
is that people think that they can get
away with things that are biology just
won't let us do nurses have been most
studied for this and firefighters and
emergency workers and people who live on
ships they all pay a price
epidemiologically we've shown higher
heart disease and more tendency to gain
weight and a variety of malfunctions and
difficulties as time goes on you can do
it but it's gonna cost you exercising
within four hours of bedtime will
disturb your sleep we give as advice is
that about an hour before sleep you want
to try and avoid active kind of thing as
an exercise certainly is one of them on
the other hand there are people who
exercise close to sleep and do very well
so I don't think we should say you know
if you're somebody who exercises
regularly and evening and you sleep
beautifully and you feel rested the next
morning that you should give up exercise
because I think that would be a bad bit
of advice you'll gain weight you'll lose
the toning that you've gotten so and so
forth on the other hand you haven't been
doing it I probably wouldn't start
exercising at night and if you're having
trouble with sleep that's one of the
first things we look at after drugs like
caffeine to try and get rid of all right
we remembering your dreams is a sign of
a good night's sleep I think that there
is a huge variation in how much people
remember their dreams some of it has to
do with when you wake up if you wake up
during REM sleep you almost always will
remember dream some of us don't remember
anything at all about our dreams and it
doesn't seem to harm them but it's not a
true thing that just because you don't
remember your dreams that you're not
having good sleep what tells you you're
having good sleep is how you feel the
next day now if you're waking up with
nightmares that could be a simple sign
that maybe your bedroom is too hot and
you need to turn down the temperature
because a hot bedroom environment and
fortunately can create fragmented sleep
and cause you to wake up often from
nightmares now eating cheese or other
food before bed causes nightmares I
don't think I'm aware of any particular
food that will do that to everybody
but it's very clear that being
uncomfortable will precipitate both bad
sleep and waking up and maybe even
nightmares
so imagine somebody with irritable bowel
syndrome who knows that whenever they
eat whatever gluten or were some
specific food spicy foods it upsets
their stomach when they're awake well
guess what if they eat it before they go
to sleep it'll upset their sleep and it
may show up as a nightmare loud snoring
is annoying but mostly harmless loud
snoring is actually a sign that there is
a blockage in your throat the mildest
form of block it just causes vibration
noise
if you've ever you know played sort of
you know with a piece of grass and you
blow through it you know that if you
blow through a tube or a structure that
can vibrate it starts to vibrate and
make noise many instruments are based on
exactly that principle you're creating a
vibration by blowing through a partially
blocked tube so snoring is just that and
if that's all it was it wouldn't be all
that bad for you but unfortunately it
usually isn't just by itself and
especially when as they say on the
question loud snoring that kind of
snoring and especially if it's
associated with gasps and snorts and
pauses is actually a sign of a very
common disorder called sleep apnea and
sleep apnea is when that blockage gets a
little bit worse than just causing
vibration and actually blocks the flow
of air in and when that happens you're
actually choking and when that gets
complete we call it an apnea without
breathing from the Greek and your body
defends itself against this blockage by
waking up because everything gets normal
when you wake up the trouble is that
then you go back to sleep and it happens
again and it can happen every 30 to 60
seconds hitting snooze bar is better
than getting up we often hear that
people have two three four or five alarm
setup before they get up in the morning
now the best thing for all of us to do
would actually be just practice sleep
hygiene and have a consistent bedtime
and actually wake up with an alarm but
of course that's a lot harder in an
actuality the best thing for us by and
large is to set your alarm clock for the
latest time that you can in the morning
to allow for as much sleep as possible
but that will allow you to go about your
daily routine and get to work on time
because if we're hitting several snooze
bars and waiting I think I believe it's
9 minutes and then another 9 minutes all
of that incremental sleep is is very
rarely that it's much more fragmented
it's a very light sleep if anything and
the majority of REM sleep is in the
morning right before we wake up so try
to protect that as best you can and set
your alarm clock for the latest possible
time you can simply become a morning
person so that the difference between a
morning and evening person appears to be
influenced by lots of things that are
probably genetic and it's not something
you can just change by training what you
can do is trick your biology into
thinking that you live in Chicago but
you work in New York and that's what
blue light does with some blue light
therapy actually using bright blue light
in the morning can help it shift those
true evening people a little bit earlier
it basically tells you that you're
actually in a different time zone from
where you are and that shifts you a
little bit so that's the approach we use
when the problem is severe and there's a
need for that it's actually shifting
when morning is rather than shifting
whether you work in the morning so you
can catch up on sleep by sleeping in on
the weekends now for the vast majority
of us this is a very common practice
this kind of sleeping in and
unfortunately in our society we we term
it is this luxury ah to sleep in and
that's because most of us aren't getting
enough sleep during the work week or
adding bricks into our backpack of sleep
debt now what sleeping and does is it
sends a cue to our our circadian rhythm
that we're trying to change time zone so
if we extend our rising time by more
than an hour to 3 worse 4 hours into the
morning you might feel better than if
you got up early but that's sleep the
next night is going to be compromised
we call this social jetlag our body is
trying to adapt if you're a New Yorker
you're physiologically your body is it
thinks you're in London and you're
trying to adjust to that time so you're
gonna be fighting your physiology come
bedtime that next night so the best
practice is to keep a consistent bedtime
schedule and try to get as much sleep as
you can now if you do have an excessive
sleep debt and you really need to pay
that back on the weekends the best way
without interrupting your circadian
rhythm would be to do that with a nap in
the afternoon because that's not going
to change your your body's physiological
circadian rhythm boredom makes you tired
even if you got enough sleep now yes it
is very true that a boring meeting or
lecture especially especially in the
afternoon may be soporific but if you're
in that environment sleep-deprived is a
bellwether sign that you're not getting
enough sleep so when people say you know
all the airport you know the airplane
makes me tired I get into play and I
fell right asleep
boredom alone of course is not a sleep
you know inducing state boredom is a
mask is a way of unmasking your sleep
tendency we in fact use that in testing
we put people in boring situations and
see how long it takes them to fall
asleep if they are fully satisfying
their sleep need they don't fall asleep
for at least 20 minutes sleep is so so
critical to our health and our wellness
and our well-being and every night does
count in light of all the things that
we've talked about remember that if it's
not broken don't fix it so do try to
implement some of its strategies or put
some of the strategies to work that
we've talked about today if you find
that you have a problem because at the
end of the day small changes do make a
really big difference especially when it
comes to our sleep one of the most
common myths that I hear is that if
unused muscle tissue converts into fat
it's really important to say that the
muscle tissue has muscle cells and fat
tissue has fat cells they are not
interchangeable by no means is it
chemically or physically possible for
muscle tissue to convert over to fat and
vice versa
fat into muscle that's Jean [ __ ] Meister
I'm a clinical athletic trainer at the
New York sport science lab in Staten
Island New York
and he's one of three athletic trainers
we brought in to our studios my name is
Janelle Mason my name is Andy Stern to
debunk 17 of the most common exercise
myths it really depends on your goals
training fasted in the morning is more
conducive to losing fat because when you
wake up you're in a fasted state and
that means your body is basically
consuming itself so it's looking at fat
storage is looking at muscle storage
that's the time where if your goal is to
lose weight and just slim down lean down
that's the best time to optimize that
window for training but in terms of
effectiveness of training in general I
don't think it really matters you just
need to make sure that if you are
training at night you are not fatiguing
yourself throughout the day so when most
people think stretching their thinking
static stretching you achieve a certain
position you hold that position and your
goal is to increase your range of motion
a problem with that is you can end up
really loose and if you follow that type
of stretching with something explosive
or something ballistic or something
strength based you now have a loose
tissue or you have a lacks joint and
your not going to be able to produce as
much force and you could also
potentially lead yourself to being
injured because you're not as stable so
what my favorite is it's the holidays
right and you have that aunt or uncle
that's just like yeah I'm just trying to
lose it like right here and they start
pinching the lower abdomen and Michael
great you can't spot reduce the part
that you want and in good news it
doesn't go the other way either it's not
like when I eat a cheeseburger it's
gonna go right to my right yeah and if
you are trying to lower your body fat
cardio isn't the best way to do it
cardio doesn't burn fat cardio burns
calories so if your goal is to lose
weight you want to be in a caloric
deficit so as a part of getting into
that caloric deficit doing
cardiovascular exercises is helpful but
if you're not eating a diet or if you're
not monitoring your caloric intake
top of that in making sure that you are
in that deficit no amount of cardio that
you do you can't outrun a bad diet and
in fact doing too much cardio can
actually be a bad thing if all you're
doing is cardio with the goal of losing
weight you can start to burn into that
muscle tissue so if you're burning into
your lean muscle tissue now you could
actually be slowing down your metabolism
you could be decreasing your bone
density and you could be making yourself
weaker and that's why I think this myth
is potentially the most dangerous and
damaging one for the general population
but it may not be as common as the
belief that I love this one one myth I
hear all the time is that muscle weighs
more than fat a pound of bricks weighs
the same as a pound of feathers so it's
not that muscle weighs more than fat
it's that muscle is more dense than fat
so in terms of you building muscle you
can add weight on the scale a scale
isn't necessarily the best indicator of
progress when we're trying to develop
our physique and often times at first
you can add muscle and the scale will
reflect that you're heavier but over
time understanding that for all the lean
muscle you have you're increasing your
resting calories burn per day that's a
long-term sustainable change in your
body as opposed to just doing cardio
sessions and going into caloric deficit
and starving yourself of course building
muscle isn't just for men women think
that they'll bulk up if they start
working out and if that's the look
you're going for I think that's great
because you're doing something that you
want to do but if you are working out
for general wellness and health I don't
want you to be afraid to lift heavy
weights you're not going to get bulky by
nature and in fact weight lifting is
especially important for women as we age
we become more prone to getting
osteoporosis so we definitely need to be
doing resistance training where our
muscles are feeling that stimulation so
that the bones nearby can remain strong
and whether you're a man or a woman you
don't actually need weights at all to
build strength I mean the myth being
that you have to go to the gym to be
doing strength training it's crazy all
right your body
is a weight so bodyweight exercises have
been around forever and they are so
important be able to push up your body
or crunch or squat or pull up and if
it's a six pack year after the muscles
themselves aren't even that important
getting a six pack is not about doing
tons of crunches a lot of it has to do
with your nutrition and Stearn agrees
abs are made in the kitchen
yeah abs are a muscle if you're gonna
target the muscle by doing crunches leg
lifts bicycle crunches oblique twists
you're essentially building the muscle
so think of it as you're building the
engine of the car and then the outside
is your body fat and how do you show off
the inside of the car you've got to
reduce that body fat so sweating a lot
means you got a really great workout
it's something I hear all the time
unfortunately that's not true either
some people are just naturally more
prone to sweating some people just have
underactive sweat glands so it means
that you're healthy and your filtration
system but it doesn't necessarily
reflect the effectiveness of your
workout but if you do sweat a lot how
should you replenish I would not say
that most commercial sports drinks are
the most efficient way of rehydrating
following a workout the plain water
isn't going to cut it either if you're
just consuming water too that's also not
the most effective way of hydrating
because hydration is not just water
there's also trace minerals that act as
electrolytes which help with nerve
conduction they help with brain function
they help with muscular contraction so
if you're looking for the best way to
rehydrate post-workout it could be very
beneficial to add just a dab of pink
Himalayan sea salt to water a pink
Himalayan sea salt has over sixty trace
minerals all of which are found
naturally in human sweat so when you
consider something like a Gatorade or
Powerade they may have four or five
different electrolytes in their blends
so Derrick falling drastically short in
terms of overall hydration when it comes
to all the minerals in your body and
after a workout you should also eat
protein immediately right if you already
have a protein rich diet you don't need
to worry so much about downing a protein
shake right after your workout now what
you are going to be depleted of though
especially if you're doing an aerobic
exercise you're going to be
pleaded of glycogen glycogen is the
immediate form of energy for muscle
contraction and that comes in way of
simple carbohydrates and sugars so
post-training it's important to
replenish that glycogen but even if
you're fueling muscles with a proper
diet they still need time off
hashtag no days off the old myth that we
should not take a day off is an extreme
there's a huge value in letting the
muscle repair itself right so every time
you do let's go back to the bicep curl
if I'm doing a bicep curl a small tear
is gonna happen in my biceps so the body
is going to repair itself
because again it's a machine who knows
how to to survive and if I continue to
do it I don't have a window of
opportunity for the body the soldiers to
jump in be like alright let's fix this
tear because this is constantly me more
so it needs some of that downtime to
again to Hue itself especially if you're
sore that's a myth for sure soreness is
the breakdown of muscle tissue it's the
chemicals released during that breakdown
it's not an indicator of oh I'm getting
stronger or I'm getting weaker but if
you're soreness persists for longer than
72 hours that could be a sign that
you're under recovering or overtraining
one month is not enough to undo a
lifetime of bad habits so it's important
to start slow find the things that you
enjoy find the physical activities that
make you feel good make that a daily
habit and there's no one-size-fits-all
approach
there's not one type of movement that
you should be doing that is better than
the other so if you enjoy dancing go out
and dance go out dancing three times a
week or do a dance cardio class or
something that gets you moving if you
like to jump on trampolines do that I
think the best movement for anyone to do
is something that they enjoy because the
only way that you're gonna stick to your
workout being a lifestyle for you is for
you to be doing something you enjoy
have it we may need to eat twice as much
absolute myth but don't do it you really
actually only need about 200 extra
calories a day over a normal American
diet and that's assuming that you're
starting pregnancy at a normal weight
sex during pregnancy hurts the baby
well cocoa butter prevents stretch marks
this is a myth i'm laura riley on the
high risk OB at New York Presbyterian
Hospital Weill Cornell I'm Deena Goffman
I'm a high risk OB at New York
Presbyterian Columbia it's okay to drink
a glass of wine when you're pregnant
we know that the recommendation in
pregnancy is that you really should not
consume any alcohol unfortunately there
is no safe amount of alcohol nor a safe
time in pregnancy when we can be sure
that alcohol won't affect a developing
fetus also I think it's important to add
that we don't think it's safe to drink
while you're breastfeeding either
because the alcohol does get into breast
milk and as dr. Kaufman said we don't
know what the safe amount is and that
safe amount may actually change for
different women your belly reveals the
baby's gender we certainly hear patients
coming in to see us and having heard or
having family members say that they can
tell whether you're having a boy or a
girl based on how the woman's belly
looks and we know that there is
absolutely no evidence that the shape of
your belly can tell us this type of
information the other myth that goes
along with gender I think is the heart
rates high or low my patients always say
that you know they come in oh it's 160
it must be girl like know if it's 160 it
means the kids moving a lot and if it's
sleeping it's gonna be 120 so it doesn't
tell you whether it's a girl or boy
cocoa butter prevents stretch marks this
is a
while cocoa butter is something that
many patients like to use we don't have
any evidence that that cocoa butter or
anything else that we can recommend will
prevent stretch marks it's probably
genetic and essentially if you gain too
much weight in one spot ie
your pregnancy gets really big you're
more likely to get stretch marks
unfortunately but it's not we're
spending a ton of money on expensive
creams because it's not gonna work
that was cheery I can give a coal to
your developing baby this is a complete
myth your baby is not going to get the
cold although your baby can get sick if
you get something like the flu which is
why we tell you to get a flu shot to
prevent your baby from getting really
sick there are some illnesses that you
can transfer to your baby but probably
not uphold I think people get the cold
and the flu confused which is which is
unfortunate because the flu can make it
really sick and pregnancy what you eat
during pregnancy can influence the
baby's palate I don't think there is a
shred of evidence to support that I
think that what you eat during pregnancy
is important because it does sort of you
know set your baby off to a good start
in terms of its overall nutrition and
good health but it's probably not going
to change the biggest palate we always
talk about nutrition and food choices
and healthy weight gain which really can
have long-term impact on your baby's
development but not specifically the
palate or what they have a taste for
pregnant women shouldn't drink coffee
that's something you can drink coffee
this is one where moderation is is the
most important thing in the first
trimester having excessive amounts of
coffee have been associated with a
higher risk of miscarriage once that
first trimester is over should you go
crazy with the coffee probably not but
it's not going to harm anything pregnant
women shouldn't eat hot dogs so this is
a myth
I think the concern with hot dogs are a
few you want to make sure that they are
well cooked to avoid infection risk and
there used to be a fair amount of
station about the amount of nitrites and
hotdogs but I think the evidence
suggests that unless you're eating
really excessive amounts of hotdogs that
it's probably okay to enjoy one I think
there are probably things better than
hot dogs to eat nutritionally but I
think if people enjoy one once in a
while I don't have a problem with it
you're not way nicer than I am I'm not
your wife anybody's eating hot dogs
frankly but you know you can have one in
in pregnancy but I think it's really
important to make sure that it's cooked
because the concern about Listeria is a
real concern so that includes the hot
dogs the unpasteurized cheeses the deli
needs all of those things are things
that we worry about so I think you know
yeah it's a myth that you can't eat hot
dogs but you should be certain it's
pregnant women shouldn't eat smoked
salmon that's a man you can eat smoked
salmon if you like it I'm not a lover of
salmon so I love it you can eat smoked
salmon this gets into concerns around
fish consumption in pregnancy which is a
huge topic and we talked to our patients
about the risk of various types of fish
so we want to avoid fish with high
mercury content so typically that would
be avoiding excessive tuna choosing
chunk light and tuna and also limiting
the number of cans of tuna in a week
there is also some concern about some of
these oily fish I guess about the
potential for toxins and so I would say
salmon in general may fall into that
category but smoked salmon i think is
safe for a pregnant woman to eat the
whole fish story is a little blown out
of proportion and I think people they're
really crazy about this whole mercury
thing I would say it's important to also
recognize though that fish has great
nutritional value to it that pregnant
women
and babies need and want so it is
unfortunate that somehow the fish story
has you know resulted in people thinking
I can't have any fish it's really the
large sake fishes where you're worried
about the mercury but then don't forget
that something like salmon is gonna give
you the DHA s which you want pregnant
women shouldn't pet cats this is a myth
this would be terrible if all pregnant
women in the world couldn't pet their
pets their cats there is a concern with
pregnant women caring for cats in terms
of the litter box and really the risk is
toxoplasmosis and the risk of exposure
isn't with interacting with your cat but
with changing a dirty litter box it is
actually fairly rare in the US for women
to come into contact with toxoplasmosis
the more important thing about sort of
the cat story is everyone worries about
the cat and the kitty litter the most
common exposure that women get to
toxoplasmosis is actually not the cat or
the litter even it's not washing your
garden vegetables because it's the cat
that has the toxin that poops in your
garden and then you pick that up and eat
it
you don't wash it or whatever so
gardening without gloves are things that
we tell pregnant women to avoid because
of that particular infection the cats
got a bad rap unfortunately pregnant
women shouldn't apply total myths
get on the plane have a good time that
said there are a few things to think
about when flying I think one of the
major issues is that pregnant women are
at increased risk for getting a blood
clot either in their leg or their lungs
when you fly the air is dry you're also
more likely just to be sitting for a
prolonged period of time and that just
ain't further increases your risk for
getting a blood clot so I always tell
pregnant women and be happy go ahead go
on those you know trips but you should
hydrate before you go you should wear
support hose or at least like you know
running tights or something that gives
you a little bit of support in your life
you should get up and walk around every
hour so people worry about the air
pressure which makes no sense because
it's a pressurized cabin and that
doesn't do anything you're not gonna
break your water and they also worry
about going through the screener right
everybody's worried about the radiation
going through the screen oh but in fact
the radiation exposure is actually
higher when you're in the sky in the
plane than it is when you're walking
quickly through those through the
security exercise during pregnancy can
strangle the baby this is a myth
exercise is actually strongly
recommended during pregnancy all of our
professional organizations all of us as
providers talk to patients about
maintaining physical activity
maintaining exercise throughout the
pregnancy really unless there's a
medical situation that comes up that
changes those recommendations so
exercise is not dangerous and in fact
the opposite it's really important I
think also this whole strangling thing
comes from this crazy nonsense that if
you get yourself into certain yoga
positions your baby can't rank strangle
itself you don't have any control over
the position your baby gets into the
baby is floating in a pool of water and
it doesn't matter whether you're doing a
headstand or you're just like chilling
sex during pregnancy hurts the baby
well that's a big myth and it also helps
to understand sort of the anatomy a
little bit I think this is where
patients get a little bit confused the
baby is floating inside a pool of water
big balloon bag and that balloon bag is
surrounded by thick muscle which is the
uterus surrounds the entire bag and has
actually a thicker portion at the bottom
so there's just no way that sex is gonna
get even near the baby dyeing your hair
is harmful for the baby this is another
big myth and we get phone calls about it
lots of questions there is no evidence
and again we keep coming back to
evidence because it's what we look to as
your physicians and there really is no
evidence out there that's things that we
use for hair dyeing reach the baby or
have the potential to cause harm the
other thing about the hair dye frankly I
tell people it's gonna make you feel
better that's really important because
for a lot of us how we look and how we
present ourselves really has a lot to do
with our psychological state and you
want that to be as healthy as possible
during pregnancy there are simple tricks
to overcome morning sickness I think
that that's a myth in the sense that
none of those things we probably simple
but I think there are ways to sort of
decrease the painfulness of morning
sickness the first thing is is that the
morning sickness can last all days so
the whole morning thing is a myth in of
itself but that said some of the things
that you can do to help it try and start
the day with something really simple
like soda crackers a minute you get out
of bed saltines something really bland
stay away from the smells the smells are
gonna make you sicker I think the
biggest thing that I've learned over the
course of my career and had personal
involvement with this one is we tell
people to stay hydrated and so they go
after the water bottle and stay away
from the water the water makes you sick
I don't understand it but it makes you
sick so what I tell patients is put
everything over crushed ice that way
you'll get the water but you're not
actually drinking it and gulping air as
you're drinking out of a water bottle
the things that I would put over ice I
would say lemonade ginger ale letting
some of the fizz out will help as well
lemon popsicles lemon slush lemon
Italian ice the reason I say lemon is
because lemon helps cut the nausea as
well I think the other critical thing
for morning sickness is it's important
to go out every day I think sometimes
what happens is you feel bit nauseous
then you feel worse then you start to
feel depressed and then you can't get
yourself moving because you're tired and
that's the worst thing you can do is to
sort of give in to it I think it's
important to get outside walk around
even if it's just down the block and
back c-sections are always necessary for
breech birth
so this is a myth although I think most
of us think c-sections are the most
common and the safest way to deliver a
singleton so a single baby in labor
especially at term so there are
certainly situations that we need to be
able to individualize for often we'll
talk to patients with twins if the
second twin is breech that may be a
great option for them and I think there
are rare situations where a woman comes
in in labor where we may recommend
and/or support a vaginal breech delivery
for a singleton I think in order to
support a vaginal breech delivery you
need to have a provider who has
experience doing that and you know the
reality is is that in the US the number
of providers that are able to do this
safely is definitely diminishing almost
to none I think the other option though
which I think we should put out there on
the table is a version which is if you
know the baby is breech and you're at
Tom is coming in for a procedure where
we under ultrasound guidance turn the
baby to head down if you sit all day
you'll have a breech baby
total myth if you sit all day you'll
gain a lot of weight and you'll have
back pain but your baby will do whatever
your baby is going to do most babies are
not breach at full-term so only about
like three percent of babies are gonna
be breech at full time those babies are
gonna turn multiple times until they get
to around 36 or 37 weeks and so it has
nothing to do with whether you're
running a marathon or you're sitting on
the bottom pregnant women should sleep
on their left side
I think the pregnant women should sleep
how they're comfortable although we know
that women as they get more pregnant
into the second and certainly in the
third trimester may not be able to sleep
flat on their back
and that's because as the pregnancy
grows the fetus grows the uterus grows
the weight that the uterus will put on
your blood vessels and some other
structures may make that really
uncomfortable and not ideal for the baby
so women get sleep on their left side
they can sleep on their right side they
can sleep on their back tilt it a little
bit but we usually aren't so strict as
to say left side only
I think people worry that oh my gosh I
woke up and I'm flat on my back did I
kill my baby didn't kill your baby if
you sleep you know flat on your back is
dr. Kaufman said the structure we're
most worried about is the inferior vena
cava so it's this big blood vessel
bringing blood back up to your heart in
your head and most people are gonna get
really nauseous right and lightheaded
and feel weird and so you'll naturally
turn you don't have to weak yourself up
to do it your hair and skin look better
when you're pregnant
I wish your hair might look better I
guess your skin probably won't
necessarily look better some women say
they glow I think that they're dreaming
unfortunately the high progesterone
levels that you get when you're pregnant
to support the pregnancy actually can
really bring out a key that you haven't
seen since you were 13 years old and all
the expensive creams in the world I'm
not gonna fix that so I wouldn't suggest
that you spend your money on it pregnant
women get flexible you know we recognize
there are lots of changes going on in
women's bodies when they're pregnant but
I wouldn't say that getting flexible is
one of them there are certain things
that happen in terms of your posture how
you stand and definitely some relaxation
of different parts of your body to
prepare your pelvis to be able to have a
vaginal birth but I don't think that
sort of traditional flexibility is what
we typically see eating spicy foods will
induce labor huh so if this were true
that would be wonderful because we could
help women um you know induce labor when
we wanted to unfortunately we haven't
been able to come up with any particular
food or physical activity or drink or
supplement that actually can in do
flavor we have medications to use to
induce labor but as far as we've been
able to tell there's no evidence that
any of those things that women may want
to try actually will be effective I
think people are just looking for
something to get out of Dodge at forty
weeks which I can totally relate to it's
probably not gonna hurt the spicy food
probably won't hurt you can do whatever
you want but your baby's in charge just
remember that yoga can induce labor we
think there are a lot of benefits to
potentially doing yoga participating in
pregnancy but inducing labor isn't one
of them certainly more women are using
yoga which may help with relaxation may
help with stress relief may help with
stretching and so I think there are a
lot of reasons why yoga may be a great
thing to participate in but there's no
evidence but it induces if only Logan
makes Labor's smoother I think overall
exercise probably gives you a better
labor in the sense that it is usually
more efficient but Yoga itself not
necessarily making it smoother there are
some things about yoga that are similar
to other labor preparation or childbirth
preparations things right breathing
mindfulness I think are similar to some
childbirth preparation things so I think
in that sense some of those things may
help you to be more centered be able to
focus be able to use some of those
strategies to help but certainly
not make labor itself natural births are
better this is a myth there are
certainly women who spend time thinking
about what they like their birth
experience to be like and I think for
some women natural birth and then we
think about that is usually earth
without pain medication and for some
women this may be a wonderful experience
but we all know that we need to
individualize the care for our patients
and for many women a natural birth may
not be better there may be real medical
benefits depending on the situation and
underlying condition to having pain
medication to having an epidural I'm a
huge fan of natural rubbers I have to
say but I do think that it takes some
preparation and I think it takes me
until preparation and I think that it's
not better or worse I also think that
there's there is another myth associated
with natural childbirth which is that if
you're induced you have to have
anesthesia because the pain is worse the
pain is bad whether we give you the
contractions or your kid gives you the
contractions or it happens naturally
whatever it's painful and some people
can cope better because they practice
mindfulness or hypnobirthing or whatever
and then sometimes people can just go
better because it's faster but again I
think it's all about everybody how it
can make their own new birth choices
there I love this one there are ways to
predict your exact due date when we give
you your due date it's plus or minus two
weeks and the reason is because your
kids in charge of might go into labor
we are not though I have to say I'm much
more precise and knowing what your dates
are than we used to be because we use
ultrasound early early ultrasound so
much more frequently
obviously there's those people who have
done IVF you know even more but again
even if you know when it all started you
do not know when it will all
and because the person who knows that is
your baby and we can't at the moment
talk to that person one of the biggest
myths that I get from my clients is that
I need to skip meals and starve in order
to lose weight it's not true
so if you skip meals it's gonna have
such a negative effect in your body that
when you do go to sit down and eat
you're probably over consumed that's
Laraine Kearney
one of three dietitians we brought in to
our studios my name is Ryan Turner my
name is Nikita Kapoor to debunk 18 of
the most common weight loss myths
the biggest myth that frustrates me the
most is that all calories are created
equally a calorie is not just a calorie
it depends on the source of your
calories whether it's coming from
caloric dense foods or nutritional dense
foods north dense foods would be more so
our cookies are cakes we can have a
cookie that's 100 calories we'll eat it
it'll digest really fast then it's going
to spike our blood sugar levels where
when we start to crash again we're gonna
crave more sugar for that energy
pick-me-up and that can make you gain
weight on the other hand you can have a
banana which is an example of a
nutritionally dense food I get the
question a lot do bananas make you fat
bananas do not make you fat bananas are
great source of potassium but for those
hundred calories you're also going to
get the fiber and the nutrients that
your body needs in that cellular level
to make sure that you are healthy and
that you're nourished and you definitely
need to nourish your body if you're
trying to lose weight when we are
restricting calories you are restricting
the energy source of your body you're
also restricting the energy source of
your brain and if that's happening then
you know very primitive protective
mechanisms start to kick into place
where your body senses that as a
physiological threat and does start to
shift your metabolic balance to burn
less because it's getting less it's kind
of like a budget right so if you have a
paycheck and you're running out of funds
you're going to conserve how much you
pay till your next page
your body does the same your body will
jump into this protective physiological
biological mechanism to reduce the
amount of energy you're using which is
why it is hard for people to maintain
weight and starving yourself can also
shrink your muscles you want to make
sure that you're not eating less than 70
percent of your overall calorie needs if
you do that's where not only are you
probably going to feel extremely hungry
and it's gonna take you off of any goals
that you're setting but you're probably
gonna start compromising your muscle
mass as well and that's where weight
loss is going to be unhealthy but while
the amount of calories you consume
matters the timing might not timing of
meals is always a big question everyone
comes to me and they kind of smirk and
they think that I'm gonna give them a
thumbs up when they say I don't eat
after 6 o'clock or 7 o'clock and I say
ah alright can you enjoy that and they
say no and I say well then maybe eating
after is okay because timing of day is
not going to affect weight loss calories
are what's going to affect weight loss
for body fat loss so if you eat a bunch
of additional calories in your calorie
surplus and those are coming late at
night then that's what's causing
something like weekend and what about
eating first thing in the morning it
depends on the body and it depends on
the person and their relationship with
food for a lot of people me included if
I don't eat a meal I usually feel like
very deprived and it's like I want to
make up for it later if that happens
then that's where we can add in like a
lot of calories personally I'm a huge
advocate of breakfast our body runs on
fuel and food as our fuel so if we have
our breakfast then we feel we have more
sustained energy throughout the day and
if you do choose to eat breakfast feel
free to go for that 2% yogurt now fat is
incredibly necessary we should not be
afraid of that we need fat in the diet
that's gonna be necessary for things
like absorbing nutrients like the fat
soluble nutrients like vitamin A
D and E and K and you also need to make
sure that fat specifically cholesterol
is what's gonna help produce things like
your hormones so things like estrogen
and testosterone growth hormone so we
need all those kind of things not only
is fat healthy but fat free foods are
often loaded with sugar or salt so if
you have a wholesome product and you're
removing the fat of it it's gonna taste
completely different he probably
wouldn't even like it but what they're
gonna do is replace that flavor with
something else and usually it's either
sodium or sugar so with sugar when we
have like a yogurt that has the fruit at
the bottom they're gonna have way more
sugars than if you had like a 2% Greek
yogurt and as it turns out fat isn't the
only nutrient you can keep in your diet
and still lose weight one of the biggest
myths I get about carbs is that you must
omit them from your diet to lose weight
or my body doesn't digest them well and
I have to admit them because I never
lose weight unless I restrict myself
it's not true and it's just not
sustainable
they're almost impossible to have a
low-carb diet fruits and vegetables are
known as carbohydrates and we must get
those for their nutrients why carbs have
a bad name it's because of the simple
carbs the carbs that you see prepackaged
that are the cookies the cakes the sodas
the potato chips they're called simple
carbs because the chemical structure of
them is usually what YouTube's glucose
molecules put together so when you have
like a smaller glucose molecule it's
easy for them to break away but with our
complex carbs they are really long
chains of carbon that usually about 18
carbons long and then by the time that
your body gets starts to break it down
it's gonna take a while and that's
exactly what we want because it helps
balance our blood sugar and also that
fiber keeps us full for longer and then
also prevents us from snacking so eat
your carbs definitely eat your carbs and
eat your bread breads delicious it's
like one of my favorite things and she
has a pro tip for finding bread with
more complex carbs read your ingredient
news
with bread it's the a lot of those
mass-produced breads that are in the
bread aisle that are shelf-stable they
can last a month without getting mold on
them and when you look at the ingredient
list it's probably about fifty eight
ingredients long they're the ones we
want to avoid when you're getting bread
get the fresh bread that comes from the
local bakery which is usually around the
deli counter area inside in grocery
stores those will have maybe four or
five ingredients it'll mold after two
days but you can preserve it by just
putting into the freezer and take it out
as you need it and speaking of bread
what about going gluten-free to lose
weight you can free for weight loss can
be a huge marketing ploy so with gluten
free there are a lot of people that do
have an intolerance to gluten or they
have celiac disease which is where the
body starts attacking itself and can
deteriorate the body but there are also
people without these conditions who are
looking to blame something like the
gluten without checking the rest of
their diet if you are honest with
yourself
recording your food checking the
ingredients and then you eat the gluten
and you feel the intolerance then great
but a lot of people will choose to just
jump in and being like gluten is the
enemy so most of us don't need to cut
out gluten or fat or carbs to lose
weight but there are some products
better left on the shelf the diet sodas
are terrible with all the additives
preservatives in them and the hidden
sugars a lot of the added sugars or the
synthetic sugars that are supposed to be
great because they don't release insulin
which then doesn't cause a spike in
blood sugar levels but internally if we
don't stimulate the release of insulin
those sugars the synthetic sugars go to
the liver build up around the liver
hinder the functioning of the liver and
then can mean two non-alcoholic fatty
disease if I'm gonna have a soda which I
have once in a blue moon it will be the
real thing yes there's more sugar in it
but it's something that I don't have on
a regular basis
better yet she says drink water jazz up
your water I'd freak to it add some
cucumber lemon yes I'll take a little
bit for your taste buds to reset but
you're getting so many nutrients from
that water and your body requires water
for it to function optimally water is
one of the six nutrients that the body
needs and when we're dehydrated it also
mimics the signs of hunger so people
turn to food a lot if they're dehydrated
not realizing that they're not hungry
it's just your body saying give me some
water on Thursday and what about juice
juice cleanses are like one of my pet
peeves if you're having a juice every
once in a while great you're still
getting the antioxidants out of it
you're still getting the nutrients but
you're removing that fiber and fiber is
key for the body to support gut health
with a lot of juice cleanses they're
hella expensive and we have this belief
that they're gonna be better for our
bodies or it's a cleansing effect of our
body realistically what's happening is
that when you have those juice cleanses
they're mostly coming from like food
sugars and then the vegetable sugars
it's a high high amount of fructose in
the body when the body consumes excess
fructose it has a spasming effect of the
GI tract that condensed to the cleansing
effect so that when we are actually
having a reaction to the high amounts of
fructose in the body people think it's
the cleansing effects because the
marketing ploys have led us to believe
that way but it's not you would be
better cleansing your body by actually
eating the Apple eating the spinach and
eating all the other fruits that are in
that cleanse that would be better for
you because fiber is our natural detox
what it does is it goes through the body
picks up like excess fat of metabolic
wastes and help cleanse it out but juice
cleanses aren't the only diet fads that
don't often work intermittent fasting is
probably a question I get all the time
it's we can kind of put in that myth
category now it can restrict calories
and at least temporarily help you lose
weight if you're only allowed
to eat food for eight hours that just
gives someone a lot of structure and
that can be very very helpful you can
only get so many calories in your mouth
in that time on the flip side someone
can get a lot of calories in their mouth
during that time as well so someone can
and I've seen many people do it they've
gained weight through intermittent
fasting so it's not just gonna be this
quick fix there's nothing magical to it
and the same goes for many popular diets
so one of the common diets right now
that is gaining popularity is the
ketogenic diet so a lot of people who
are doing that are just eliminating
carbohydrates which is why that's hard
to sustain because your body does need
carbohydrates for a reason to be honest
there's not a lot of research that's
saying that that is something that is
helpful there's maybe a lot of research
in mice models but that hasn't been
transcribed into human studies and well
people have lost weight on keto it's
often not without side effects they're
eliminating whole grains and legumes
certain fruits and vegetables and really
increasing their fat intake which
although fats are important excess of
any nutrient can cause metabolic changes
in your body that will impact your
cardiovascular health your physical
health your metabolic health so an
example would be patients that we're
seeing in the clinical setting are
following ketogenic diets are seeing
weight loss however are coming with
higher cholesterol markers they are
coming with higher LDL markers they're
coming with more irritable bowel
symptoms they're coming with more
gastrointestinal discomfort the truth is
there's no one tool that will make you
magically lose weight I think the most
prevalent concept around healthiness is
bio hacking which is this idea that you
can defeat biology you can work around
your genetic predispositions your
metabolic parameters and that is
actually not true and the reason for
that is because you cannot defeat
biology you cannot hack hunger you
cannot hack access to healthcare you
cannot hack motivation and this idea
that you know again if those results are
there you're going to be able to feel
more satisfied is also not true
so this bio hacking works on this
concept and this belief that you know
you can work your way and you know fix
your body and that prescribes to the
social construct that it is up to you to
change that and that's also why most
diets don't work they're hard to sustain
their heart to maintain so the results
are very temporary which is why we go
back to something trying something new
it's important to focus on behavior is
rather than outcomes where you should
start is record your food a simple food
log to lose weight it's really just
being honest with yourself identifying
your foods and the hidden ingredients
that could be contributing to excess of
hundreds and hundreds of calories per
day take olive oil olive oil is great
but when we cook with it we usually free
pour it into a pan each tablespoon of
olive oil has 128 calories now if you're
pouring in like six seven eight
tablespoons
with your vegetables you're getting
almost like a thousand calories that you
don't need so pro tip for cooking with
olive oil put it in weights your pot
your pan is hot once it's hot add 1 to 2
tablespoons of olive oil and then adding
your vegetables when the pan is hot
enough it will disperse easier and then
you'll use less also once you put the
vegetables in some water and moisture
will come from those vegetables and will
add to the liquid in the pan so you
actually don't need to add excess in and
if you are being mindful of what you eat
a whole idea of cheating kearney isn't a
family I don't think there is any cheat
meals I don't like the word cheat I
think it gives it this it gives us this
like higher power like oh this is really
bad and you know I can't believe I did
this I completely fell off the wagon
no remove that because then you're gonna
want it more you're going to feel even
more guilty about it
you go out you're socializing your China
one of New York's like best restaurants
that's filled with cream and butter
enjoy it just try to get a salad to
start and filling up on salads is great
way to cut the calories and then have
like one of the appetizers that are not
in line with your health goals with your
table and chair because sharing is
caring
and there's more good news you can still
lose weight while drinking occasional
alcohol if you're sticking to the
cleaner foods and by omitting all the
foods that you tend to enjoy in the past
by omitting alcohol trying to increase
your exercise and then doing this like
detox fat all in one go it's
overwhelming and it's setting you up for
failure so doing it in stages and being
more realistic about what you can change
now and then work towards it well what I
usually recommend to my clients is take
care of your food now you understand how
your body feels when it's nourished
understand like how your gut health is
supposed to be supported and then we'll
focus on alcohol and working in the
exercise but the thing is no matter how
much we care about it
weight definitely isn't everything I
think one of the biggest myths around
weight loss and weight is that
overweight equals unhealthy on normal
weight equals healthy as defined by the
BMI category BMI is a very inaccurate
measure of Health because it is just
looking at your height and weight
without taking into account what your
metabolic factors and parameters are
what is your physiological health your
physical health your sleep your mental
health your relationship to food you
know and and I think it's very important
to factor those things if you really
want to define someone you know as
healthy and if we're not going to look
at it more holistically
I think what that does is it
marginalizes people in bigger bodies
plus not everyone can lose weight even
if they're putting in the same
that's a very common myth that everybody
should have has the same ability to lose
weight and if everybody eats the same
way they're gonna look the same way
which is very untrue and that's been
correct and the reason for that is I
think it's important to understand that
someone's weight is a factor of so many
different things it is so complex all
the way from your genetic
predispositions your past your family
history your past medical history your
you know relationship to food as you're
growing up because not everybody has
access to food because health is about
inclusion access connection joy
physiological well-being and we have to
take those factors into account so the
myth that all neat freaks have OCD is a
common one most people who are clean
just actually care about being clean and
that's totally different than having OCD
also there are knows five stages of loss
it's just a myth that's Laura Goren one
of three psychologists we brought into
our studios to debunk some of the most
common mental health myths so the myth
that most people with schizophrenia have
multiple personalities that was a very
old way that it was understood but and
it's been proven to not be true so with
with schizophrenia it's not another
personality what it is though is a break
with reality and a part of ourselves
maybe for instance that believes that
someone is out to get them okay so
that's a really common one with with
schizophrenia so the myth that all neat
freaks have OCD is a common one it seems
like it's almost a popular cultural
thing that people say to each other you
have OCD when somebody is like
organizing their bag and in reality OCD
itself the the illness has different
components in one of the subsets is the
the keeping things organized and clean
but it has to be at an obsessive level
where people are thinking about it all
the time and so that itself is really
uncommon most people who are clean just
actually care about being clean and
that's totally different than having OCD
bipolar disorder is not simply mood
swings it's a very high elevation of
maybe a positive mood in a very low
negative mood everybody has mood swings
but with bipolar disorder it
it's not just that it's you know severe
forms of you know elevated mood or
depressed mood and they cycle through
that and so sometimes it could be shown
as symptoms of like a manic episode it
might be somebody like hypersexuality or
not sleeping at all and things like that
it's not simply feeling good this is a
common method I hear people throw this
one around a lot to anxiety itself is
thinking thinking thinking and just
imagine yourself going into the worried
thoughts of what if what if what if this
happens what if that happens and it's
unremitting and it goes on for hours for
some people sometimes it's more passing
for others but being stressed out about
something as humans we're wired to be to
handle stressors and we've been dealing
with an onslaught of stressors since the
beginning of time you know going to work
taking the subway
coming in contact with other people look
you know that that can be stressful that
can be stress inducing unless you have
an actual like panic attack while you're
taking the subway that would be more of
an anxiety reaction whereas the stress
of taking a subway as more stress based
you know everybody feels anxious let's
say before presentation or you know
before an exam but an anxiety disorder
is the extreme form of that where it
becomes you know it get interferes that
somebody is daily functioning this is
actually a really important myth
sadness is an ephemeral reaction to
something it's an emotion and by by
definition lasts a few seconds it can
last like 10 minutes but on average we
have an emotion it passes and then we
have another emotion the thing that
tends to bring us from sadness is your
passion is rumination which means
thinking and thinking and thinking about
the thing over and over and over again
and that's how we then go from sadness
to depression but it's not an immediate
thing we all have moments of sadness and
we just we just allow them and let them
pass we tend to be okay but if we get
caught up and getting ruminating and
thinking about all the reasons why we're
sad that's when we tend to go into
depression so to the myth that
depression is not a real illness it is a
real illness and in fact it can be
incredibly debilitating in order to
classify as having depression we have to
have some kind of a lethargic kind of
behavior where we have trouble getting
out of bed I mean there are different
there are different ways of depression
but one of the primary one
has this kind of but they're called
neuro vegetative symptoms like where we
can't sleep where we can't eat there's
also a kind of depression which is this
thymio which it has an an had only a
component into it which means less
pleasure and things that we used to
enjoy which is another kind of
depression and a lot of people will
describe like oh I used to love pottery
and now I can't even like I can't even
look at pots you know like something
just totally changes for them when
they're deeply in this in this state of
depression talking about painful things
that you've learned how to sort of cover
over can initially be more painful but
in the interests of working out things
that if not dealt with straightforwardly
are going to come back to bite them I'll
say another thing about that is that
sometimes patients wonder what's the
therapist going to feel if I say thus
itself like can the therapist handle the
level of despair that I sometimes feel
and on those occasions when the patient
has the strength to put it out there and
see how the therapist responds the fact
that the therapist can can handle it is
a big step toward the patient then being
able to handle it there are reasons and
they may change over time but I think
the thing that I would want to debunk in
that respect is the idea that there's a
single reason so that if you if you
handle that then you're gonna be freed
of that and there's there's not in most
cases there's not
you've got to discover the reasons and
the plural that you're depressed and
what you can do something about and what
you can't the myth that only women get
depressed couldn't be further from the
truth however women are twice as likely
to experience depression so the reason
why I oftentimes people think women have
a higher rate of depression than men is
because of maybe hormonal changes life
circumstances and stress the only thing
that I like to think about is that women
might express their feelings in a
different way than men do so sometimes
men might you know act out behaviorally
whereas women might for
they're an internal experience and so
they might be more likely to see a
therapist if that's the case when people
have gone down the road of eventually
deciding to go on medications for an to
antidepressants they don't change your
personality they change the symptoms of
depression they can also work for
anxiety so typically if we have just
typical symptoms of depression and
anxiety will be given an antidepressant
as what it's called an SSRI and that
will help us regulate the symptoms of
our just up and down of moods and the
way I describe it to people is it's like
going back to your baseline you when
it's the right medication but it doesn't
change your personality your personality
your you so in terms of the myth that
will always be cured from depression by
antidepressants the research shows that
the most effective thing right now for
depression is actually therapy and then
for people who need antidepressants
therapy and antidepressants together
another effective form and it doesn't
not everybody has to take it so even
with people who are taking
antidepressants is important to still be
in therapy the myth that bad parenting
causes mental illness I think is a trap
because parents are all too ready to
take responsibility and to feel guilty
about all sorts of problems that their
children have so there's no point in
reinforcing that and harming and
damaging the mental health of parents if
you think that your parents caused your
mental illness you're going to end up
endlessly complaining about your parent
what can you do about the way you were
raised you can do something about what
it's left you with in the present around
LGBT adults and youth there's so many
myths associated with with mental health
and a big part of it I think is
unfortunately because the profession
that I'm in had a really dirty history
along these lines and that in the DSM
which is our diagnostic Statistical
Manual until 1973 homosexuality was
actually listed as as a disorder and
after a lot of pushback and studies and
and LGBTQ kind of Rights being
integrated into into
theory we realize that that was really
outdated and since then and dsm 3 it
stopped being and unless somebody has
specific anxiety related to being gay
then they're not diagnosed ever with a
mental health related disorder
associated with it the same is true for
being trans actually that it's only if
somebody has what's called like
dysphoria where they they don't like
their body that they then have a
diagnosis but just being trans and of
itself isn't a disorder anymore you know
to the question about what role mental
health plays in the attacks of gun
violence unfortunately that's been a
mischaracterization of people who have
severe mental illness is that they're
more likely to commit crimes and with
guns it's not that people with mental
illness are more likely to be aggressive
it's the people who commit these crimes
have access to guns and they tend to be
really self-loathing like that's kind of
the primary thing that makes people and
have a lack of empathy that seems to be
the things that make them be more
violent and aggressive those are better
predictors than any type of a metabolic
disorder people talk about a whole town
like on the news the whole town was
traumatized by the shooting for instance
right and it doesn't work that way and
that's actually one of the most common
mental health disorders that I've seen
mischaracterized in that particular way
is PTSD people seem to think that by
virtue of having experienced a
potentially traumatic event that you'll
have these particular realm of symptoms
that include hyper vigilance there's
impulsivity there's so many different
realms of what comes up for people after
a trauma and I've heard people say you
know because I was traumatized because I
was there on 9/11 for instance well a
whole city was there we have really good
numbers about the number of people who
ended up having PTSD and they're
actually really small when something
like this happens on a major tragedy
like a gun shooting or a you know 911 or
any other type of tragedy like that
people tend to be resilient there's a
big myth actually even within the mental
health field saying that there are
prototypical ways to respond to grief
and loss and that's in pop culture as
well that people have these ideas that
there's one may degree
and if we're not devastated and deeply
traumatized that somehow when we're in
denial or unfeeling and that's not true
in fact since the beginning of time
we've been dealing with death we have
different ways of dealing with it and
sometimes sometimes we're relieved that
the person dies because we didn't have a
very good relationship with them or even
if the person if we love them and we
feel really connected to them but they
were sick we're relieved that they're
dead because we don't want them to
suffer anymore people tend to feel
really guilty about being relieved after
a death which is a very common reaction
to death
there are knows five stages of loss it's
just a myth and it's one of the most
popular myths out there and it's one of
those things where people who aren't
very psychologically minded will come in
and say oh my gosh I must be in the
denial phase of loss or I must be in
this phase because I'm not you know I'm
not dealing with it yet in reality I
just think it's one of those things that
makes us feel safe like if we can
imagine these stages are ahead of us
then we can feel better about where we
are and so I think that's why it's so
popular
however I've seen the flipside which is
why it can be damaging when people have
losses and they're judging themselves
for not having this prototypical series
of stages and they're not based on
reality or evidence or anything okay so
people are gonna hate me for saying this
but and this is so common in the dating
world like people if you ever look on
people's profiles on dating profiles
they always say like I am an nyf beer I
don't even know what they have to say
but it's always about how there are
these certain you know myers-briggs
score and it's really popular these days
myers-briggs and in fact a lot of
organizations use it and really you know
based a lot of their testing on it again
there's no validation around any of
these studies and so well it might
resonate for people and that is
something that you know just like when
we talk about you know I'm a I'm a
Gemini because I do this you know it
resonates for you the idea of being a
Gemini and you might act in ways that
remind you of this description of what
it is to be a Gemini but there are no
empirical tests to say that you are such
this thing there are personality tests
but myers-briggs isn't one of them the
myth that therapy is going to be
exclusively about the
or predominantly about the past and not
help you in your current life or not
give you a forum for talking about
what's happening today and yesterday
there's a reason why people hold on to
that myth and the reason is that there
was an early version of psychoanalysis
that held to the idea that people's
personalities were formed in their first
5 years and that the past was strongly
formative of the present it sometimes
can be helpful to say that there was a
pattern that was established in relation
to people in the past and that can give
you some perspective on what's happening
in the present so making reference to
the past is not necessarily a bad thing
but it should never be because this
happened therefore you're having this
problem now it's not an explanation
it's only a way of getting perspective
on the present I think oftentimes people
might say oh that why not go speak with
a friends who's a good friend and they
can keep things confidential but a
therapists are trained to work in a
particular way to help people deal with
specific problems they're facing
therapists are different than friends
because even though your friends might
be willing to for example hold a secret
therapists really treat things in a very
confidential matter and they're willing
to explore things that maybe a friend
would be uncomfortable exploring
actually the fact is that most people
who come to therapy are among the
stronger people and the reason is
because they have the courage and the
strength to look at themselves which is
not an easy thing to do in various ways
I think it's because the people who come
to me are people who've already decided
to work on themselves good therapists
don't force their patients to talk about
something they don't want to talk about
to the contrary I think that even
encouraging a person to talk about
something that they're not ready to talk
about is counterproductive
the problem with hitting pain points
right on the head is privacy for one
thing people are entitled to their
privacy therapy isn't just an
opportunity to spill so I think having
people's privacy when their privacy is
respected that makes them more confident
to open up
but the other problem for that is that
the therapist needs to be thinking that
there's a limit to the tolerance of
everybody including the therapist for
how much pain they can tolerate at any
given time and so respect for people's
anxiety about getting into some of the
more difficult things in their lives is
also part of the process
it's like hydrastar the only ones who
are able in this country to prescribe
medication they do us it's called the
psycho farm logical consult where they
will go through all of your history and
that's something they do if you want
that and I say if you want that because
it's really important as a psychologist
for instance we always try therapy first
it's like it's the treatment of
preference for all clinicians in fact
they've done all these studies that have
shown that therapy first for several
months before you then even think about
a medication is the best course of
treatment for people because that way
you can really see what is white and if
you then still want to do medications
it's certainly something you can talk
about but but you don't have to do
medications it's up to you and your
therapist to if it feels like that would
be beneficial to you I would not say
that most therapists consider that
therapy has to go on forever
but I think when you're interviewing
somebody and considering them to be your
therapist that's one thing to ask about
how do you think about how long should
this should go on and when do you start
to think that maybe it's time to end it
how do you break up with your therapist
do not break up with your therapist in
an email or a text or a phone message
you've got to be direct you've got to
say I've been thinking that maybe it's
time for us to stop but then that can't
be the end of it if you haven't already
said it hopefully you have already said
it in one way or another in the
preceding sessions what I've been
looking for is this and I see how it's
been happening in my life and maybe give
an example or two but it's not like you
feel you have to convince the therapist
I want to be sure to let people know
that there are lots of ways of getting
good psychotherapy at a reduced fee so
there are institutes where people get
advanced training beyond their
and all those institutes have training
clinics where people are treated at a
low fee and some people might think that
the higher the fee the more skilled the
practitioner which is not necessarily
the case but certainly in that case it's
not true
[Music]